la vidéo reste les supporters de javel
et big n et al gore il ya la france qui
joue ce soir hier sa belle fille joue ce
soir contre le fait qu'on y va les gars
est ce que vous voulez pas qu'on allait
faire un petit tour parce qu'on nous
l'avait demandé hier sur twitter atteint
jeu oui oui tout à fait passé comme ça
on s'ennuie un peu son on va faire un
petit tour sur i télé au niveau mondial
car pascal praud ils sont directs à ce
qu on y va tous les disques ont pour
atout si elles venaient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la vérité sera sympa et que la visite
soit parce qu'ils allaient travailler
avec des années monsieur s'affairent à
l'aller ce monsieur ne vous inquiétez
pas
allez-y mais si ça passe sa part voilà
10 2 mais voilà l'équipe de france
contre cypher et voilà les bleus
[Applaudissements]
allez
ça se voit
si vous cherchez un job in the world les
gentils mais ça allait
[Musique]
jamais soyez sympa oui nous ce que vous
pensez du match ce soir
nous sommes dans une émission à la
valeur ces démissions sérieux mentionné
que nous avons le oui on va on va gagner
on va y aller par 3 0 ap à la plupart
sur laon sera promet du groupe après
bestial de finale nigéria
mais j'ai aussi nigeria et j'en ai
ensuite quart de finale contre
l'allemagne allemagne on passe demi
finale contre le brésil est terminée et
ouais c'est l'impression que ça
s'enflamme un petit peu comme un saint
jeudi le jt a son mot à dire et
l'algérie en demi-finale cette coupe du
monde est déjà gagnée pour la frangine à
l'algérie j'ai trouvé l'amour de notre
équipe et cette équipe a retrouvé
l'amour du club
continuer la vérité est que les
supporters merci la france merci les
approuver et le charles de gaulle
voila mail merci je pensais me dire
merci à la merci on fait venir
[Musique]